[Música]
boa tarde pra vocês todos e o meu nome
alfredo moser
então vou explicar para vocês como
começou a a lâmpada de moça né
a partir de garrafa pet que vocês hoje
em dia já tá vendo aí no mundo gerando a
lâmpada de moço por aí né
foi quando um guia de tarde eu saí pela
dom pedro primeiro né
encontrei o chico xavier saindo da
residência dele e atravessando um asilo
dos idosos
aí a senhora junto e o aí eu fui para
cumprimentar ele precisa de ver que
poder que o chico xavier até na mão
então a gente falar do chico sempre
falam bem dele né
foi um grande homem na face da terra
está continuando sendo todo todos nós
o ensinamento que deixou na falta até a
todos e aí veio o apagão quando veio o
apagão eu não sabia como fazer e eu
fiquei preocupado com a população que
tinha racionamento de energia aqui no
brasil né
e olha pessoal ea ficar na totalmente na
escuridão
aí um dia de tarde
a minha esposa convidou pra ir na casa
da minha prima 1 e chegando lá na casa
da minha prima tinha uma mesinha de
tarde tinha uma garrafinha dessa aqui
torcida com o sol da tarde mas refletir
a claridade
mas antes disso
e o curto tempo e nosso chico xavier nem
falou pra mim moça você vai ter uma luz
na sua vida só se à noite você se você
do povo né
e ele ainda falou assim a moça é quem
pratica o bem aqui na terra
venha a receber a luz divina
aí eu como falando com ele
aí ele falou assim mas eu já tô de idade
mas quando eu vier a falecer você lá na
sua casa vai ver a luz divina
a icab do dia que ele faleceu na parede
eu vi o sudário de chico xavier igual o
sudário ea luz divina vem em cima de mim
a coisa mais bonita do mundo então
emociona muita gente e aí com isso da
minha prima
no outro dia eu peguei uma garrafa pet
de deus que eu não sabia como começando
em pois a água que é um telhado na minha
borracharia lado como da oficina e
coloquei aí veio aquela claridade eu
chamei o meu menino e foi leão joão
agora na cheia da escuridão aqui né
aí no dia eu já pego uma uma garrafa de
dois litros dessa grande e coloquei água
dos dois potinhos de água sanitária por
causa da dengue e paga não ficar verde e
sempre mantém a água limpinha e um
pouquinho de si de era de filme com isso
aqui agora mas agora não tem mais tem o
sonho de ponta do estado de mesmo e
sempre botar tampa o preto vermelho
amarela nunca branca colocar porque
senão daqui um mês ou dois diz farinha e
assim e aí você aí outro dia de tarde e
chegou um colega meu
aí eu falei pra ele porque você não não
coloca a garrafa pet lá no seu
restaurante manu chao é por aí
aí ele falou eu vou ser criticado comum
com meu irmão que ela é a garrafa pet né
ensinamos você vai ter uma grande
economia de energia elétrica
a icab de uma semana ele passou aí
perguntou moça como é que você
mas na garrafa disse não você pega porém
duas tampinha de água sanitária é um
pouquinho pra filmar você abrir na telha
um diâmetro de 100 milímetros na telha e
aí você põe a água igual falei e encaixa
em nossa massa plástica né e coloca no
lugar que você já tem energia de graça
aí depois dessa dessa lúcido no
restaurante na minha borracharia na
oficina que tinha aí a turma começou a
falar
a chama o jornal pra fazer uma matéria
no jornal nem aí eu chamei o jornal de
uberaba quando saiu no jornal de uberaba
que saiu a matéria
aí veio o joão eurípedes sabino e do
joão sabino também é depois ele convidou
o carlos barbosa da cemig
aí ele viu a alunos de lá da garrafa né
aí ele falou assim musa que nome que
você vai dar dessa graça lapa daime da
garrafa num show jorge eu vou dar o nome
de lá produzimos e de samus eu gostei da
idéia e é bom mesmo então aí como
colocar o nome de lâmpada animoso e aí
através dessa medição da da cemig mudou
a v m dia além da da lapa não deu entre
40 a 60 watts de de potência né
aí o jornal da manhã fez a matéria
também através dessa matéria que só na
bahia depois veio de vida de uberlândia
que veio nem uberaba não veio de
uberlândia fazer matéria lida da inapa
demoroso aí através dessa matéria e em
os acho que o são paulo jogue na nota a
secretaria de meio ambiente ligou pra
mim moça você pode fazer uma colocação
de lâmpadas aquino no parque ecológico
- eu disse eu falei pra ele não eu vou
eu faço a colocar a nossa colocação lá
aí eu fui lá e coloquei um ás 22 24 lapa
de mozer lá aí através dessa filmagem o
passou na televisão ganhou um espaço na
na globo lá que passou
dali aí eu comecei quanto em continue
colocando na residência todos os
vizinhos dando if animado com um com a
energia de graça em 2001 quando não
quando meu pai fez aniversário de 90
anos
eu fui convidado meu pai não fui lá no
aniversário dele
aí de repente chegou o meu sobrinho do
lado e chamou assim o timbu vem cá eu já
estava na saída de vinca o uberaba
voltando né
aí ele falou assim ah vocês aqui todos
vocês sabem porque lá na mais felipe no
todo mundo lá tá tendo energia de graça
graças ao meu tio aqui alfredo bosi que
o dia descobriu latina que dias pegava a
garrafa dessa aqui enche de de lama né
e fazia casa para as pessoas carentes na
aiea um colega dele e viu fazendo a
matéria da garrafa que ele descobriu no
computador diz a senhora vem cá ver um
brasileiro que tá desenvolvendo
iluminárias de através de garrafa pet
aí ele viu ele gostou e lacre dias né
e começou a distribuir na redondeza lá
nas filipinas a e hoje em dia tem mais
de 15 países lá com uma prognose e ele
também para a noite e depois com um nos
de luz dentro uma luzinha e com a placa
solar também ea depois dessa invenção da
lâmpada de moça um casal que tinha já
era casado a esposa dele estava grávida
e estava esperando a criança então como
eu tinha muito gasto com querosene com o
motor lá que funcionava pra energia para
a energia para a residência dele na casa
aí ele diz assim mozah a depois que
coloquei essa essa lâmpada de monza que
a gente ficou até emocionado eu também
fico emocionado no que deu pra
economizar dinheiro porque deu pra
comprar o enxoval da criança então isso
é muito muito bom e gratificante pra nós
todos né
e aí teve um garoto também de 12 anos
que não poderia estar dentro da casa
dele na casa dele lá é só porta não tem
janela e é aquela escuridão total né
aí ele falou pai dentro de casa não pode
estudar e na rua no posto aqui não tem
nenhum harvey pra pra fazer sombra para
mim é que você tem que dar valor no meio
ambiente nós o youtube e aí a depois que
o iraque dia já começou a colocar lá na
casa dele
aí ele falou o pai agora sim eu posso
estudar então a gente fica muito feliz
do garoto e principalmente a garotada
todo mundo precisa estudar e ele era com
luz de querosene aquele antigamente era
que as coloca igual eu novo também o meu
pai também não deixava estudar aqui era
na verdade de de querosene e eu tive
poucos tudo só o primeiro o som 5º ano
também e eu não tenho muito estudo então
que eu falar vocês têm que entender um
pouco talvez eu tenha água tratada num
normal não
então isso tudo a gente fica muito
emocionante e fui convidada por dentro
dessa invenção tão simples e barato que
vocês sabem que é uma garrafa pet que é
jogada no chão no lixo e
vai-nos bueiro entope tudo né
isso é uma qualidade que o pa o nosso
brasil para o mundo em geral né então e
que vem com 11 refrigerante pra gente
bené mas utilizando ele você usa como
uma lâmpada de moça minha depois
utilizam e quando sua visita de jogar no
no chão no meio ambiente no mar
vocês sabem que o mar ele ele mesmo se
limpa ele joga o que é ruim ele joga
para fora então nós também tem que ser
igual a uma nós mesmos se proteger limpá
o próprio a região que nós caminho nosso
nossa nossa coisa mais bonita é o nosso
meio ambiente então todos nós tem que ir
lá pra essa parte aí que água água água
é vida né
depois dessa invenção tão simples barata
o mozer foi convidado pra coréia do sul
aí fui eu a jornalista claire aqui do do
brasil eu como falo só o português e mal
e então ela foi traduzir por quem mais
fala tudo estrangeiro la la que dias da
outra região da coréia do sul
língua então o rapaz nem trouxe a
vassoura que também pra mostrar
aí eu eu levei uma vassoura de presente
para dar poucos dias
a iac também essa vassoura que você nem
sabe muito nem sabe do que é feito de
que é feito o teste não isso aqui é
feito de de fita que marras embalagem de
caxarias de e papelão de madeira então
isso vai tudo com aquela boca de lobo e
isso aqui seguro até 1 60 ou 70 quilos
quase um boi de o peso que isso aqui é
forte
aí eu levei essa vassoura e dei de
presente do lago dia no dia que eu
cheguei nele e ele me deu uma camisa
também representa o devia ter trazido a
camisa que também mais que sim
aí quando quando eu dei a avançou ele
chegou até beijar vassoura
eu falei pra ele lá a criança vá você
ensinar a população de vocês aí pra para
eles ganhar um dinheirinho deles também
que isso aqui vai ajudar vocês também no
meio ambiente aí eu não sei se aqui
também tendem a surgir deve ter eu falei
ontem aqui em uma embalagem e assim e
uma voz é essa aqui é uma que está
comigo essa vassoura tem uma na coréia
do sul e uma que eu dei uma palestra no
em ouro preto tem outra doença e de
thala e várias garrafas de pet onde eu
vou sempre ou deixe também há a
universidade eu já dei a a apresentação
em uberlândia também sobre a lata de
monge e nós escola também quem chamar e
tem mais ainda essa história que eu faço
também para a procissão pra evitar de
kemal cabeça das pessoas pode de vento e
não apaga e tá tirando do meio ambiente
também
e o resto que sobra vai para a igreja
pra igual não estão reformando a igreja
santa luzia vai pra lá pra poder também
é reciclagem para juntar dinheiro para
uma obra que está em reforma da da
embaixada brasileira né
aí lá na embaixada brasileira eu fui da
onu do foi convidado para o evento é
dada ele não pára de mozzi depois desse
evento
todo mundo gostou lá tinha fizeram até a
casinha lá com a lâmpada de mozzi
lâmpada de mozzi tudo lá
clareando e no seu placa solar que o
iraque dias também hoje iluminando para
baixa e todo mundo tirando foto e
tirando foto comigo com com todos e que
foi lá que dias também
foi muito legal muito gratificante e
através dessa que todo mundo gostou
o professor de lá ele também traduzir
sabia falar em português é famoso
eu gostei tanto de você que eu vou
convidar você só pra onde eu disse eu
não sei mas o onde você convidar eu vou
é para a embaixada brasileira
eu falei pra que o que vou fazer na
embaixada deles morreu só vai ser à
noite eu vou dar você vai ter aula pra
um e vinte strecht 24 aluno só falar
sobre a lâmpada animoso ai eu falei
sobre a ampla de monstro pra eles e aí
eu falei pra eles
vocês sabem porque o moça chegou tão
depressa aqui há aqui na embaixada
brasileira e falou 'não você chegou de
táxi né
aí eu disse assim não foi de táxi eu
digo ah ah ah claro devam eu vim porque
o hotel tem a van que trazia a noite não
foi de van não você está enganado
vocês são estudados mas tem que estudar
mais
aí eu falei foi através de uma invenção
aqui em uberaba foi a de uma caixinha de
fósforo que foi a invenção do santos
dumont
o avião que você vê que a potência que
hoje em dia tá um avião nosso que
transporta é 600 e 700 pessoas de uma
vez
então isso emociona muita gente aqui né
e eu também perguntei para eles quanto
as invenções o thomaz neto tinha feito
eles também não sabia responder uns
falava uma duas ou três eu falei 'não
você tem que estudar mais ainda também
foi em 2000 e 300 e
e 32 invenções que tomar certos teve e
hora do as invenções também do santos
dumont que deu para nós também porque o
nosso brasil também que todo mundo tem
que agradecer e eles me tomar 200 ea
depois também dessa invenção do mozer o
como a invenção do monza atravessou o
mundo igual o chico xavier falou que eu
ia fazer eu ele e fazer o bem público
daqui só que eu ia fazer o bem do povo
de lá mas eu não estava sabendo que o
povo de lá eu pensei que como ele tinha
um centro de l'aquila ea minha oficina
na esquina de cá e eu também quero uma
uma igreja do divino espírito santo no
nosso bairro também né
então esse meio não todo mundo ajudando
e fazendo bem para eles de cá e pra lá
e assim foi e há hoje em dia que eu
entendo que o chico xavier falou que eu
ia fazer o bem do povo de nó a esse povo
do outro mundo lá da áfrica que eu
mostrou muito também de s
[Aplausos]
[Música]
esse povo da da áfrica passa muita fome
há aqui a vontade era via levar 11 um
avião e pra eles distribuíram mas agora
como tá osilan eu fiquei já muito já
mais calmo porque eles têm lá perigoso
para clarear e vão economizar energia e
vejam comprar o pão de cada dia deles
então isso é muito gratificante
gratificante pra gente e também como a
energia do mundo está na ênfase em pina
na áfrica tentar mais de 15 países e tem
mister dão aula de mo de demonstrá lá na
exposição lá pro demozzi e também em um
museu museu do amanhã em que eu fui
através dessa obra tão semba e hoje em
dia tá lá sozinha foi convidado para lá
também e eu já agora tenho um livro
receber um livro da da lâmpada e mozdzen
e também eu também fui através da sua
lâmpada eu fui convidado pra carregar a
tocha olímpica 2016 daqui também no
brasil em uberaba carreguei e eu tenho o
chan
a tocha olímpica nem através da lâmpada
de mimoso carregando ela aqui em uberaba
a vocês todo mundo geral a lapa de mozzi
foi caminho roda rota da tocha olímpica
do rio 2016 e também o vitor que trouxe
a lâmpada de volta na que na origem do
ataque do brasil que foi o alfredo bosi
que inventou a primoroso né
então hoje em dia tem a de lampião
também ano de leve e tem porte agora na
comunidade quando de led no nos estados
unidos também têm lá pela decon de led
também lembrou de mozzi e
enfim e também o meu pai também falava
pra todo o sol nascer todos e vamos
usufruir quem plan
então ea minha mãe é da falou no final
alfredo você nem sabe essa lavra da sua
vai revolucionar o monitor aí
e cada um de vocês que tiveram a luz
dessa nem na sua residência nem que foi
bonito e vai eliminar a meta de vocês
pra tudo quanto é coisa que você
precisar ali vocês vão analisar como que
uma luz dessa faz um benefício pra vocês
dentro da sua casa e uma energia que
você vem do sol que o sol trazer boa
energia pra vocês todo um bom estudo e o
desejo a vocês que sejam bons alunos bom
pai de família e um a senhoras bodies
senhoras mãe e uns bons alunos e os
professores todos agradecendo